Hungry for some pizza?
We all like a good pizza pie to chow down on, but it turns out
there's a simple scientific solution
to maximize your pizza experience.
It all comes down to the area of a circle - that equation you may have heard of when you were young,
where the area is equal to pi*r².
"r" being the radius.
If we plug in some numbers, you may notice something interesting.
For example, since we measure pizza in inches in North America,
the area of an 8 inch pizza is roughly 50 square inches.
We simply take the radius of the pizza
which is half of the diameter,
so 4 inches in this case, put it in the equation
and voila.
But if we do the same thing for a
16-inch pizza,
which has a diameter that is two times bigger,
we find that, even though your intuition
may say it's twice as big,
it actually has an area of over 200
square inches. Which is four times more pizza.
This is because the area of a circle
increases with the square of the radius.
And yet most of the time, the difference in
price between an 8-inch pizza and a 16-inch pizza
is not even two times more
expensive - let alone four times more expensive.
In fact, NPR did a study of
over 74,000 pizza prices in America and created an interactive graph
to show exactly how the price of pizza changes with size
and how much more pizza you
get when you order a large.
For example, a 20 inch pizza has more area than
two 14 inch pizzas or six 8 inch pizzas.
Yet it's almost nine dollars cheaper on
average than getting to 14 inch pizzas
and over thirty dollars cheaper on
average than getting six 8 inch pizzas.
And this is the pizza equation:
The bigger the diameter of the pizza the
more bang for your buck.
But why is pizza so tasty in the first
place?
We actually break down the science
behind why pizza is the perfect food on AsapTHOUGHT
all while making some delicious recipes.
Check it out if your taste buds can handle it.
And subscribe for more weekly science videos!